let's jump to this next story check this
out we have this from TV line Fox News
issues cryptic statement in Wake of
calling Biden a wannabe dictator will
head's roll so we all saw this
apparently Fox News had a panic attack
because I I just absolutely love look we
just talked about the expose for Matt
Walsh how Fox is woke and pushing woke
indoctrination on their employees
an employee made a Chiron that said
wannabe dictator referring to Joe Biden
Fox News panicked because they were now
being criticized by their peers and
media because yes the people at Fox News
care more about the opinions of MSNBC
and CNN than about their own viewers
so by all means
uh well look I can only say this the
people who watch the show are currently
not watching Fox News yeah yeah how can
we get that message to the Fox News
viewer but they brought this statement
and it was very very vague to say the
Chiron was taken down immediately and
was addressed a spokesperson for Fox
News told CNN a statement Fox admitted
the message was inappropriate and that
it had taken steps to address the
situation internally but declined to
elaborate on specifics well apparently
they reprimanded the guy the producer
who then resigned I want to call that
story but I do want to mention one thing
I do think that Chiron is inappropriate
well I'm sorry inadequate it didn't go
far enough that's what I meant to say it
didn't go far enough and I think I often
tell people this before the show like
hey make your arguments academic because
an academic statement and I mean I mean
that like a direct intelligent sounding
argument works so much better than a low
brow insult wannabe dictator applies
stuck across and put out a video at 6 30
today hitting the nail on the head with
the hammer about why Joe Biden is a
wannabe dictator but I think they could
have put up a more powerful and serious
Chiron that no one could have complained
about it could have said president it
could have said president speaks after
unprecedented move of arresting Maine
political rival
I mean that right there I felt I feel
would be substantially more powerful
than just saying wannabe dictator I
don't feel that actually conveyed a good
message yeah I agree I mean I I actually
think it's much more powerful as you
touched on when you have PBS you know
trying to quote unquote fact check Trump
as he's speaking in a much more academic
sounding way but Fox is out here
apologizing for this how many times has
CNN uh apologized for the the chirons
that they had underneath Donald Trump
right so I have a couple polls exactly
and fox shouldn't be either so I have
one here about angry Trump turning
briefing into propaganda session
um Trump uh trying to rewrite history on
coronavirus response uh here's another
one CNN Trump has no plans to claim any
personal responsibility for inciting
serial bomber thus of course implying in
the Chiron that he should be accepting
responsibility for inciting an actual
terrorist yeah but the diff is the left
and the right I mean the left are the
ones that lay down in traffic over
climate change the left are the ones
that go to the BLM protests and burn
down St John's Church so the left does
demand that that we uh respond to what
their philosophy is the right doesn't so
the right looks at CNN and they're like
that's ridiculous give me a break and
they go about their business so and to a
certain extent I'm going to applaud the
left for being as tenacious as you could
possibly be because they're not going to
rest until Fox sends out the apology no
I got it shout out to all the antifa soy
boys yeah you know we want to criticize
them for being soy boys but those are
the guys that are screaming thumbing at
the mouth and going out and actually
engaging in real world activities
meanwhile Fox News which is supposed to
be the opposition
is actually completely on board with
everything they're saying and is only
secretly or is only on the surface
somewhat opposed to these things I got
to tell you right now spread the word
Fox News should be done
hands down the fact that this stuff is
now coming out the fact that there's two
big stories one
that they're indoctrinating their
employees this with this crazy cult
stuff and two they're bending the need
of CNN
CNN reaches out to Fox News and foxes
are like we we took it down oh you know
oh oops what are the odds producers hope
we can still be friends what are the
answers producer was like I don't want
to work here anymore I'm going to run
this crazy Chiron and they're like we
took care of it internally because he's
like I'm quitting so it doesn't you
can't touch me I'm gonna write this
crazy thing and I'm leaving because
that's what it feels like to me like if
you're the person who wrote this you
knew that wannabe dictator would get you
in trouble right I mean at the very
least even if they weren't as you know
even if they weren't giving in to the
other side they know it's unprofessional
they know it's not blah blah blah I feel
like this producer was like I have one
last shot to do something before I leave
and this is it one last shot that I
would have come up with something better
like remember he had to do it on the fly
yeah the New York Post guy who who
hacked their uh their their home page
and wrote all those articles like that's
the way you go out with it that's true
maybe that one had that guy
yeah that was a while ago and I remember
watching that in real time saying that
game I was on my on the on the New York
Post app and I was like that does not
say what a speaker didn't do that he
didn't say those things or actually
that's the way to go out on a bang well
Ben Shapiro is really pushing it this
time yeah for those unfamiliar with a
story where uh somebody he was working
at New York Post right yeah and he
started just writing a whole bunch of
crazy fake articles and attack headlines
yeah just stuff you can't say on this
segment like just yup way over the top
very crazy stuff but that's not just
quitting your job that's that's saying
like I no longer want to work in media
and I want to go flip Burgers yeah yeah
or become I've won the lottery and I
don't need this job anymore you know I
mean they're similarly qualified right
media I'm not even saying this as a joke
or sarcastically Burger flippers have
more skills than journalists I think
that's probably true that it's not a
joke I mean they're probably you could
probably argue that some of these
reporters writers journalists quote
unquote at these Outlets know how to use
a Content management system which is
like okay there's some skill involved
but dude learning how to log into a
website ain't no big deal now you want
to talk about somebody who's got to make
a burger to specifications come on you
take the average journalist and say make
me a medium rare burger and they're
gonna screw it up they're not they're
not gonna know what to put in it how
much do you put aggrad you don't put egg
I don't even know how to make a burger
I'm not gonna go and rag on a burger
flipper they know how to make food I
don't what's going to happen is they're
gonna end up flipping burgers and then
when you tell them they got the order
wrong they're gonna call you racist
that's basically the level at which
they're qualifying and this is
no problem somewhere else but this
really does bug me right there are
people who flip Burgers who get paid a
lot of money to do it more than many of
these journalists couple hundred
thousand dollars a year if you're like a
top level dude who makes the best
burgers ever but typically at that point
you have like a staff of chefs yeah but
there are people who work at Great
diners they make real burgers with real
beef seasoned perfectly and they get
paid less than these people yeah that is
a travesty of American capitalism I'm
sorry
look bro it could be a McDonald's burger
they're bringing me more pleasure than
these people are right well they're
improving my life McDonald's is is like
a I I would give McDonald's like a c
minus you know it's like it's tasty it's
like you know you're drunk at night and
you're hanging with your friends at two
in the morning and you know if they're
open you can get a burger and whatever
it's like a turkey has these things
called wet hamburgers they're very much
like that you don't turn on CNN at two
in the morning you know when you're out
about buddies but I want to say this in
the utmost certainty a person who
produces cheeseburgers is benefiting
Society yeah unquestionably oh no doubt
somebody's got to go to work don't have
a lot of time they want to go with their
family and just grab a nice a burger and
fries I'm not talking about gorging
yourself I'm talking about a good
cheeseburger bacon maybe caramelized
onions what do what do these BuzzFeed
people produce listicles about
celebrities I used to like their quizzes
when they're stuck to quizzes
I think even a bad cheeseburger has more
to offer I I agree it's it's sustenance
but I will defend good writing so I
don't want to love all journalists
together like you can still read an
article in multiple outlets and a very
well written a good a good writer is is
rare and it's as good as a good burger
which is rare there's tons of lousy
burgers and then you've got a great one
there's tons of lousy articles but every
now and then you read well and you're
like that's a great writer and that has
value There's real journalism yes James
O'Keefe good right just good writers
though like like I'm talking about like
Prince I agree I print yeah the the
issue is
that that guy who wrote the there was
that article we were just reading um
Colorado Sun I think it was it said BLM
protests slowed the spread of coven like
that guy that's beautiful so imagine you
went to a diner and you said let me get
a cheeseburger and instead they brought
you out like a garden salad no no no no
Garden salads have nutrients they
brought you out like scum from the
bottom of a table scraped off with a
paint scraper and put on a plate
something completely inedible that
smells terrible and they said that's
your food but I can't eat that and if
you did eat it you'd get sick it would
poison you these people produce the the
the uh they produce brain poison they
want you to eat things that poison your
brain that's what they make it is a
negative on society and then there's the
combination of the the gifted writer
who's also poison and I'm thinking of
the guy who wrote the profile piece on
Pete Buda judge
um oh that was amazing when he walked me
through an apps in the Cathedral of his
mind I thought holy cow like that's a
very beautiful poetic line but look at
this guy doing something
just
of his mind that I thought boy you're a
gifted writer and you're a total like
like shill at the same time that would
be like you going to a restaurant
ordering a cheeseburger and they bring
you out a steaming pile of feces and
then put whipped cream on it you're like
okay dude look you've you've put whipped
cream on it please but it's not it's not
sustenance it is a net negative so if
you look at the the holistic picture
here people flipping burgers they're
keeping us fed
sometimes people eat too many burgers
and they should probably switch to the
garden salad periodically but you know
at the same Diner where it got a little
line cook he's not getting paid as much
money as these these jerks in the
corporate press but they'll get you the
food you need and in the big picture the
people writing these articles that are
lying are poisoning this country yeah so
when people say the corporate press is
the enemy of the people when Michael
malice says stuff like that you look at
the Washington Post trying to lie about
the Bud Light stuff this is what they do
they lie about everything it is
remarkable the degree to which they lie
but people are waking up to it they're
starting to realize it's BS and I'm glad
to see it I also wonder if as dangerous
as the LIE is the Omission as when you
will open up the Washington Post and
they just don't report the story it's
everyone saw it it happened yesterday
and they just ignore it it's like as if
it didn't matter and that I think is
just as dangerous well exactly so there
was a yougov poll in 2017 that showed 60
of Democrats believed that Russia
actually tampered with voting tallies in
the 2016 election okay now no one in the
media ever actually said that that
happened but they just repeatedly said
Trump Russia possible collusion
and it got to the point where this had
been repeated so many times your average
person just took for granted that it
happened
and then they went to the most extreme
version of what they were hearing
because of course no one in media was
willing to clarify that that wasn't what
was happening so even though they didn't
say anything openly dishonest at least
the ones who didn't know that there was
literally nothing to the allegations of
collusion they were convincing people to
believe something which was totally
factually inaccurate thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time